you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy networks American
history podcast each week I Dave Anthony
Reese story from American history to my
nemesis Gareth Reynolds No Deal what the
topic is going to be about now you say
it and there's a lot of meaning behind
it it's not great it's hostile what
you're saying it's a it's a you have a
take me down aura where your what is
your problem well I think you're trying
to take me down
well I don't know what you've just
labeled me your nemesis
I don't if it was a label or a frozen or
organic I name that came out that it's
very applicable to your alright well
let's call it shady character alright
alright let's just let's what let's just
start and start the show
yep okay and called it quote is
jam-packed jammed I'm the [ __ ] guy
they look as Garrity but it's good is it
and this is not gonna come particularly
now hit him with the puppy you both
resent sick argument
my friend yeah it's not great for kids
well then they don't need to come into
the studio and read it which reminds me
if you want to see what's on my hat you
can go to the all things comedy YouTube
page and you can see okay
come on how hard is that David guess
who's going to placencia that's a place
in California sort of I believe it's an
Orange County I'll be there this Tuesday
oh the day this comes out October 8th at
7 p.m. at a place called the clubhouse
the clubhouse I'll be there that was
great
pretty good that's all I got this week
got an album that'll be coming out till
then probably to be some no plugs also
we should say that we're going to be in
Madison on October 18th and Milwaukee on
October 20th and you find out any of
that stuff at dial podcast.com and then
yes I will go to Europe where we've
added a show in London on November 22nd
we're gonna be in Stockholm my dad's
taking up most of the tickets for that
sake I his okay great
Oslo Amsterdam Glasgow Manchester London
I already said that sold out sorry
Birmingham Cardiff Dublin Copenhagen and
then of course the London show on the
22nd and look you guys have trains you
guys and take the trains between all the
shows yep go to all of them yep because
they're all gonna be different topics
yep see you might as well I'm even going
to all of them yep I might do that I
haven't decided yeah yeah we might have
some comics just standing for me and I
don't do it great perfect good sell
that's something nemesis would be
excited about not sure why we had to
take this turn oh you're not sure yeah
bombas Obama's our sponsor they are
their sock people their sock company our
people I mean the people who are into
socks well that's every person all into
sex I do it before I put my shoes on
thank you look we all love to refresh
our snack drawers but when's the last
time you refreshed your sock drawer I
gotta say well I didn't have a lot of
money and I know another friend of do
this you're really really low on funds
and you just buy new socks and refresh
all the socks it's a tremendous feeling
yeah when your socks are key yeah let's
say when I travel the amount of socks I
take is absurd Yeah right there with you
if you can't remember the last time you
refresh your sock drawer it's probably
time for an upgrade bomba socks are made
with comfort innovations like arch
support a seamless toe a cushioned foot
bed all socks peak for super comfortable
when they cut sorry they come in
hundreds of colors and styles making
them perfect for men women and kids I
have their I have the the little where
they call the little ones are just on
your feet booties booties I got the
booties I got the hiking ones yeah which
are great yeah those are good for the
hikes which I like to hike yeah and they
make my feet fly let me go back to the
fresh meat yep
Obama's has a new line of merino wool
socks that are made from soft warm and
naturally a moisture wicking merino wool
designed with all Obama's classic
comfort features from keeping cool and
dry on your morning run to staying
comfortable in your office's freezing
air conditioning balm those socks are
ready to work as hard as you do and for
every pair of socks you buy bombers will
donate a pair to someone in need very
important
bombers are what feet daydream about yep
mm-hmm when when if your feet are just
disprove it
yeah I can't thank you because we're
hanging in how do you feel what's going
on what's going on what do you think
about right now foot yeah buy your
bombers at bombas calm /table today and
get 20% off your first purchase that's
a bo MBA Escom a slash dollop for 20%
off bombas dot-com slash dollop we're
also brought to you by Casper Casper is
a sleep brand that makes expertly
designed products to help you get your
best rest one night at a time now you
you're a big fan big fan you are make it
came in a box you open it up it puffed
up like a got my dad one yeah bad one
yep
you sleep on it with your cat Jose Jose
takes up half of the bed a couple of a
couple of indents when you get up in the
morning yeah yeah now the joke I'll let
you know when you've struck something
that's not real it's you just you just
kind of sink into that bad boy a little
bit both of us do and it just forms
around your your body like hugs you a
little bit yep I love it so if you
receive a hybrid mattress you're
encouraged Oh Matt Casper products are
cleverly designed to mimic human curves
providing supportive comfort for all
kinds of bodies the original Casper
mattress combines a multiple support of
memory foams for a quality sleep service
with the right amounts of both sink and
bouncing you got the bounce don't you
big boy what's your problem
are you what Casper now offers three
other mattresses the wave the essential
and the hybrid the wave features a
patent-pending premium support system to
mirror the natural shape of your body
like a pair for me the essential has a
streamlined design at a price that won't
keep you up at night and the hybrids
combined the pressure relief of the
award-winning foam with durable yet
gentle Springs
remember when we stopped her at the
airport here's going Dave you got dad
bought it right to your door in a box
and then it pops open and gets bigger
hassle free returns if you're not
completely satisfied they also offer a
wide array of other products like
pillows sheets all that good stuff that
you sleep on free shipping and returns
in the US and Canada you can be sure of
your purchase the caster's 100 night
risk-free sleep on it trial so get $100
towards select mattresses by visiting
casper comm slash dollop and using code
dollop at checkout that's Casper comm
slash dollop and use code
checkout terms and conditions apply nice
and nice and then we are also partly
brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace of course a website company
and that I have my common website you
your comedy website yeah and then we
have them for the dollar sources and of
course the dog webpage so we clearly
enjoy the Squarespace we're all in yes
100% 100% yes look it's a great website
company I like it because I really like
the templates I think it's super easy to
use
you know you can publish do all the
things you do on a website
yeah magical stuff very straightforward
so even if you only just announced an
upcoming event or special product jump
in there get on get on Squarespace get
it done the a beautiful templates
created by world-class designers you
ever sit around and think what did
Squarespace used to build their website
promoting Squarespace I doubt that tree
falling in the woods home I don't I've
never thought that everything is
optimized for mobile right out of the
box a new way to buy domains and choose
from over 200 extensions analytics that
hope you grow in real time built in
search engine optimization free and
secure hosting nothing to patch your
upgrade ever 24/7 award-winning customer
support so look if you're ready if
you're ready to start if you're ready to
do this or it's a Squarespace it head
over to Squarespace comm for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
you use the offer code dollop to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain that's squarespace.com enter
code dollop okay do llo p for those of
you do you know me don't ever do that
again
do llo p yeah you know me 1967 yeah Lord
Jesus panel yeah yeah all right Ginger
Baker that's right just passed away oh
did he die today he did yeah hey no he's
still alive well this is quite a roller
coaster you've gone on just now isn't it
yeah Palo Alto California working-class
town back then now it's not now it's one
of the richest places on earth sure you
know the usual suburban homes
nice Long's main driver of the town was
Stanford University okay the university
moved its Medical Center there from San
Cisco and together with the city of the
open an industrial park that could
uncheck to new residents so pal allowed
to have great schools okay because it's
near Stanford you know some said the
best in the country once school
Cubberley High School stood out in the
district for its innovation oh I just
got a text I should turn this off but I
bought my dog a new toy and he got the
squeaker out in under five minutes we
just stick to the and the thing I bought
it it said it's a D most durable toy
let's just cover at least the squeak
around five Coverley high school it's
home yeah Coverley high school okay and
it was and people took notice around the
area that it was just larry i mean that
it was doing some new stuff yeah okay so
it's innovative it's an innovative
school the principal allowed teachers to
Trout unconventional curriculums and
teaching tools where students could
roleplay in order to experience what
they were learning about okay one
teacher at Coverley who frequently used
simulations was 25 year on Jones the
school's history and social studies
teacher he he joined the school in 1965
he was a Stanford Graduate a master's
degree okay he's pretty pretty fancy
sure he stood out a bit he didn't dress
up in a suit and tie like the other
teachers he's in a suit in a title well
no he's got a short sleeve shirt
oh okay so he's like Dennis Fromm's yeah
he's going short sleeve II he wore a
plain white nup we're playing whiten the
plain white button-up shirts and the
roller shirt sleeves up right so
criminal activities far as the
conservatives are concerned he also
caused Custer's because he would bring
in guest speakers like communists a
Klansmen and a member of the American
Nazi Party
Highschool yeah okay so he's kind of
he's kind of showing the kids like well
this is what these people are like right
and he would love them to come in and
then I mean ideally you're not like oh I
want to do that ideally you know talks
about outdoors things well that guy's
[ __ ] in the head well also I would say
that the thing that we do here is like
avoid the tough subjects so it's like
yeah that is good I mean I'm sure it's
interesting and it's not as long as as
long as it's framed correct yeah then
not like when the Klan's guys about to
come in like this next guys awesome you
know like you just have to just be like
all right look these guys are real
douchebags one of them come in here for
some reason yeah so so Jones was uh also
an actor and a fiction writer and he
would bring his creative side to the
classes okay and he's teaching the kids
with the simulations especially when you
say simulations you mean the the
bringing in the speakers or there's more
no there's more he would like do like a
roleplay thing like a you know like you
would have kids act on the guy this is
why this is up applicable to okay
whatever
he used simulations because he wanted to
show all sides of a situation
experimental experimental teaching was
very big at the time 1967 Jones was an
exceptional teacher and all the students
wanted to be in his class like if you
were in his class other students were
jealous okay for three periods a day he
taught contemporary history class okay
and in March of 67 he was teaching about
the time just before World War two
focusing on Germany okay some of you
know history but Germany during World
War two know I know this one not great
good guys not know sorry ice bad guys
not kind of everyone's a bad guy but
they're specifically really bad the
worst guys yeah there are the worst guys
okay by far okay well the Japanese not
great either there's a lot of killing
happening okay okay
a student asked how the Germans were
able to carry out the atrocities of the
Holocaust good question great question
how does a country come to that place
and Jones didn't have an answer okay
later that week he informed his classes
there would be some role-playing the
next week mmm now these are all pretty
clean cut and cut like 15 year old kids
right so that Monday and students
arrived in Jones's class to find all the
chairs in a row Jones had darkened the
room torn down all the posters and put
on vogner on the stereo and these are
these are children they're 15 okay he
told them there was going to be an
experiment your face wait a minute every
student who participated will receive an
A Okay if they didn't participate they
had to go to the library if they just
went along they would get a see if they
were active they would get an A if they
went to the library they got enough okay
let's so it's a big deal because an A in
this class would help you get a college
like it's a really big shirk line an F
would really hurt and he wasn't using he
wasn't as usual smiling self on Monday
they were very used to a very happy
teacher they they called him by his
first name Ron yeah it's super sixties
he's intense okay on this day this is
not something they'd seen before he was
a lot of fun to be around
and now he's sang they had to call mr.
Jones they they have to call him mr.
Jones yeah before that before they oh
I'm wrong right right all right okay
sorry I think I'll call in mr. John I
was like the viewers God you're calling
me mr. Jones right okay so he lectured
about discipline and started by calling
disciplined beautiful okay
he described quote how an athlete feels
having worked hard and regularly to be
successful at a sport how ballet dancer
a painter works hard to perfect a
movement he dedicated patience the
dedicated patience of a scientist in
pursuit of an idea its discipline
that self-training control the power of
the will the exchange of physical
hardships for superior mental and
physical faculties Ron the ultimate
triumph okay what's happening right now
we then ordered the class to sit up
straight before they could sit how
however they liked he didn't care how
they sit now he's like you have to sit
in a specific way but their chairs are
all like in a line right okay Jones
didn't lectured intensely on the
importance of good posture telling it
telling them and it help them breathe
easier and made them concentrate better
uh-huh the students all sat up straight
in their chairs and next Jones walked
down the aisles and criticized each
student making sure they sat perfectly
where the feet flat on the floor and
their hands on the small their back
forcing their spine up straight so he's
trying to like answer the question of
like how did how did
Germany get away with this [ __ ] but I'm
still waiting to find out how he told
them sitting like this that made them
breathe easier like I said and if
they're breathing easier they could
think better and their answers would be
more concise sure so once Jones was
satisfied with how everyone sitting
everyone sitting the way he wanted he
had them all stand up and walk outside
the classroom
okay and then he told them to do an
exercise run back to their chairs and
sit down at attention as each on them as
fast as possible and it was chaos the
students are rushing in and making noise
bumping into each other
Jones says you can do it faster and so
they do it again and again until they
tighten it up and the more they did it
the better they get at it
in a short amount of time they'll move
quietly to class and to their seats in
an orderly fashion within
in seconds okay learned a lot today at
school well it took I took hardly any
time to get them there so Jones time
them with a stopwatch and then he was
ready to move on he was like okay you've
done it the one student put his hand up
instead quote um I think we can do it
quicker not this kid and so they did it
there's all my gas kid near the end of
the hour just decided to quote pushed
the tolerance of the class for
regimented action he introduced new
rules students must be sitting in class
at the attention position before the
late Bell all students must carry
pencils and paper for note-taking when
asking or answering questions a student
must stand at the side of their desk ok
they practiced short silent reading
sessions and then were asked questions
and students who responded in a sluggish
manner reprimanded and forced to repeat
it again and again until it was a model
of punctuality and respect ok
I miss Ron what's up mr. Jones
the intensity of the students response
became more important than what they
were talking about students were
rewarded for making an effort and were
acknowledged for it in a crisp and
attentive manner
now if students are down with all this
well yeah ok
but they they look at this as like he is
actually doing something yeah ok and
they did everything he asked he couldn't
tell if they thought it was a game or
they enjoyed the discipline or wondered
if he could push them even further so
the next day he comes in it's Tuesday
and when he arrives he finds something
till he unexpected they're all sitting
in detention the way he made them sit
before yeah that's the deal
but he didn't think that they were gonna
keep doing anything what is this point
what is he doing well he was planning to
resume the lecture and just talk about
what they had done the previous class
but because they'd all like sat back
mm-hmm but then he goes well it seems
like they want more of the experiment is
their curriculum is there anybody you
know it's a teacher making up teachers
back then you could do your own
curriculum okay so you decided to teach
Nazi posture yes okay so they're sitting
there stone-faced rigid in their desks
waiting for instructions so he decides
well keep the experiment going okay but
now he didn't know where he was taking
it well that's not good well so he
because he didn't expect it he thought
he'd come in and give a lecture but
overall this is your experiments over
you don't then go well what am I trying
to prove now let's keep proving so now
he'd be making up as he went along again
so it's like improv fashion yes he's
like scatting an experiment he's just
not like scatting Hitler yeah yeah about
about Bosch I sit in the chairs yeah
so I go to the chalkboard and he'd
written strength through discipline the
previous day and today he writes
strength through community and he wrote
communities a bond between individuals
who work and struggle together it's
raising a barn with your neighbors
it's feeling that you were part of
something beyond yourself a movement a
team la raza a cause la raza means of
movement he lectured that the community
was more important than the individual
okay at that point he gave them the
feeling of being part of a group by
having them whisper together okay and
then start chanting together okay and
then stopping their feet at the same
time he also had them practice yelling
strength through discipline together as
a class okay
quote first I would have two students
stand and call back our motto then add
two more and finally the whole class was
standing and reciting it was fun the
students began to look at each other and
sense the power of belonging everyone
was capable and Eagle they were doing
something together this gave them a
feeling of being part of something
bigger than themselves outside the
schools this things that was going on
with Black Panthers and other groups
in the country and then he gave the
community a name they called them the
third wave hmm
yeah Jones was a surfer and in serving
lore waves come in chains one right
after the other and the third wave is
usually the strongest wave okay so with
strength through discipline Jones told
the students that by sticking together
they would be the third wave of America
the strong wave the strongest wave okay
he told them they could all share yes
sir they're gonna be that they're gonna
be the third wave of America yep what's
happening is he is he like simulation
yes
but it's quite a jump in today too
oh yeah so his he now is he now going
like there's some real power here
well he's yeah he he's teaching them
through a simulation what it would be
like and at the same time he's feeling a
little powerful I do not like I will
once again go back to what I'm feeling
which is that I don't like the question
he's trying to answer and I don't like
the starting of how he's doing it he
told them the entire class would share
grade if they all work together by doing
their homework together
they would all get A's he want him to
share answers and they started working
together so that everyone would get an A
this wasn't as popular with the really
good students as it was with the not as
good this is but for the students like
myself this was like this would happen
at times where they'd be like look you
fail together you succeed together yeah
I'd be one of those kids like all right
[Laughter]
but now all the students in class were
answering questions because they were
working together as a group and the
smarter ones were teaching the less
smarter ones and so we introduced a new
rule they all had to answer by first
saying mr. Jones and they had to answer
in three words or less now before
classes ended on the second day
Jones told them to the third
members saw each other if they saw each
other in the hallway or wherever oh here
we go
they were to hold up their hand in the C
shape like a wave
he thought see look like a way of
cresting if two members saw each other
and didn't salute it meant they didn't
share the community's values and the one
who didn't salute would be kicked out of
the third wave so this is happening
but he's got the three classes and it's
having the same effect in each class
meaning that they're all in yeah y'all
get me on board right what's not to like
the again that he's trying to answer a
question about Nazism so when the belt
quote when the bill sounded ending the
parrot asked the class for complete
silence with everyone sitting on
attention I slowly raised my arm and
with a cupped hand I saluted it was a
silent signal of recognition they were
something special without command the
entire group of students returned the
salute so they now had a salute and
slogans a name and a name on Wednesday
Jesus everyone sat down for his first
class and he decided just again he's
doing this all on the fly he decided to
give them third wave ID cards so he
looks at his desk and he sees a pile of
blanking next cards so he hands them out
and says these are third wave membership
cards okay he while while he's handing
him out he knowses the class is larger
there's 13 students who have cut their
other classes to be here is this a
school what is this place this just as
classrooms it's not a school well it
seems like a liberal of school I'm
waiting to find out that someone in this
story's a ghost that's not gonna happen
well you feel it like this isn't an
episode of scooby-doo
well feeling a little scooby ish
well I mean they probably weren't
allowed to cut the glass but they did
they wanted to be a part of whatever was
happening like they liked it the day
before so they okay but yes but like the
idea that like really where are you
going like oh we're gonna go this other
guy's class now it's like oh okay
No
so he's handing out the index cards
before he does he takes three cards and
he draws red X's on them the student who
got a red X they were a little special
they were to be informers I mean it's I
mean it's like 1984 the school they were
to report to Jones anyone who was not
going along with the community values
come on what for example if an informer
caught a third wave remembered not
saluting or on or off campus mmm-hmm
they would be reported at Jones mmm-hmm
who'd kicked him out of the community
and send them to the library how long
until he thinks he's Jesus because it
always starts out kind of BIOS he's a
teacher he knows what he's sure they
always know they always know until well
I just talked to God he also made the
rule that if they gathered in groups
bigger than two people they would be
kicked out of the third wife so no three
third wave members together on in class
on campus off campus wherever okay now
while only three people in each class
got the red X yeah other people started
informing okay right to get it as good
grace sure
and they would turn in names people who
had done stuff that they thought was
wrong Wow and this is I'm sorry
Wednesday this is Wednesday
I mean hang on to your [ __ ] because
this isn't escalated timeline Jones
created a new membership process now a
new member had to only be recommended by
an existing member and then Jones would
issue them a card I get the cards are
blank and what's happening with the
index cards is people are drawing a wave
right like the like the little slip it's
like that fancy so they've each got
their own individual card but it's a car
that's part of the community right a new
member just had to show his knowledge of
the rules and pledge obedience to the
rules and then Jones would let them in
okay that day
the principal gave Jones the salute at a
faculty meeting lines are blurring
[Laughter]
what's the principal doing okay so the
principal knew what the experiment know
that he knew that Jones was doing an
experiment about you know Nazi youth he
understood that but Joseph's not
updating the principal about anything
and the principal didn't expect Jones to
check in because he had approved the
experiment and then left Jones alone
like he'd done with many other
simulations he thought it was an
effective way to teach kids about
totalitarianism right he's like this is
this is fine so here's here's him
talking to the kids I explained how
disciplining community were meaningless
without action I discussed the beauty of
taking full responsibility for one's
action of believing so thoroughly in
yourself in your community or family
that you will do anything to preserve
protect and extend that being I stressed
how hard work in allegiance to the other
would allow accelerated learning and
accomplishment I reminded students of
what it felt like being in classes where
competition causes pain and degradation
situations in which
were pitted against each other in
everything from gym to reading the
feeling of never acting never being a
part of something never supporting each
other it's just creating a community
sure totally
a healthy utopia new rule oh good
they're never supposed to criticize or
question the third wave that's the big
one the big one
eliminating questioning authority with
one rule pretty big pretty big but one
student Shari towsley stood up and asked
when they could say what they felt about
the third wave promote her and he sent
her to the library for the rest of the
semester
oh my god well it's the what for the
yeah good God okay well by the way I
mean yeah that sends a real clear
message
all right you go to the library does
anyone else ever want to try that I
don't think so yeah it immediately makes
anybody who's gonna go I'm not gonna
question it cuz I don't wanna sit in the
[ __ ] library it's the warden beating
the snot out of the new prisoner to be
like all right and she's just got she's
got an F right he says he's going to the
library more than one student was sent
to the library he also told them that
he'd ruined their reputations with the
other teachers whoever asked this
question back on Monday is like um or a
night last week or whatever so students
since we just disappear and no one was
talking about it right so these students
who so students would get knocked on by
the informers and then he would say
you're in the library and you'd come
into class and they're just be oh Mark's
desk is empty right but then no one
would bring it up because they don't
want to be like hey what happened to
mark we go to the library that's right
right you like it I don't know what to
think
[Laughter]
so sherry believe that he would ruin her
reputation like he said with the other
teachers right you tell she tell I
believe it sure so she's in the library
and the librarian wants to know why
she's in the library instead of in class
cuz she's supposed to be in class and
sure he's not telling in the librarian
keeps pushing so finally she tells the
librarian
now the librarian is freaked out and she
tells sherry that she was born and
raised in Nazi Germany okay and it
sounded like that's exactly like what
was going on in mr. Jones class yes yes
yes it's very similar it's actually a
condensed timeline it's very good what
he's doing so she told the librarian
tell sherry not to take it sitting down
and to do something this is some Fight
Club [ __ ] who is real I'm worried this
is like the game mature I didn't know
what to do because it would have to have
an impact and be in secret mm-hmm so
when she goes home she tells her parents
and she decides to make anti third wave
posters which she signed under an alias
and she came up with the alias the
breakers as in Breaking Away
huh so she's sort of making it seem like
there's another group out there
sure called The Breakers her father
drove her to the school so she could put
up the posters at night but when she
arrived the next morning they were all
torn down so while the experiment was
going on she would go every night to
hang posters and they'd be torn down
the next morning eventually she would
bring a ladder and go up so high that
they couldn't all be torn down okay
I also probably not be read was that say
up there
what she what is it flagpole there's a
piece of paper can't see what the hell
it says brick break break break break
break break room break yeah whatever
yeah if it was important to be down here
I'll be way down low anyway
yeah anyhow so they were a bunch of
ideas of what to do coming out of his
classes now he gave a lecture about
strength through action they started
making posters and putting them up
members had to pass out flyers tables
were set up in quarters and members of
the third wave would try to enlist other
students you know I'm saying yeah okay
no it's it's when you first when you
first hear this as I did the the rapid
pace of it is astounding but also the at
this point and you don't even need to
confirm or whatever but at this point
it's like how aware is everyone as to
what's going on because you would think
that the second that even if it was your
class where you have free rein that you
if another principal or another teacher
saw you like recruiting students to come
to your class it's weird it's like class
teachers don't normally compete with
each other you know that they don't they
usually don't compete for students again
the other teachers in the school already
don't like him right okay
so I don't know how that all works out I
don't know the the Dinan is legitimately
like yeah the feeling of the librarian
and the feeling of other teachers there
is one where they're like he is just
fully going rogue yes yeah for sure
alright yeah but there's also a lot of
simulations of the school so there's a
sort of gray area and then I didn't read
anything about what other teachers I
okay because I think they're mostly all
dead so I just heard what old students
said okay okay
so right so strength through action
right they're putting up posters trying
to list other students a senior rich
sloth's is passing a table between
classes to members standing there at the
table when they've got the poster up
behind him right okay right
they say would you like to join and then
he says well what's what's it about and
they say I want to get an empty index
card and make a seat they say strike
through unity and he says right okay I
get what you stand for but what's it
about
and they say strength through unity and
he's like okay so you can't tell me like
what it's about and he is so no I don't
want to join your group because I don't
know what it is and then one of the
members came around the table with a
spiral binder and a pencil and said
what's your name and rich said I'm not
gonna give me my name and then the
second guy came around and rich thought
he was about to get into a fistfight
okay and he says I'm not giving you
names and then on that day in the school
there were fistfights breaking out
between third wave members and other
students one member quote my only
feelings at that point were that we were
in the right and the people picking the
fights were in the wrong he's in the
third way that they weren't seeing what
we were up to was nothing bad it had a
lot of energy and excitement and a lot
of purpose oh my guess so this is just
the greatest teacher of all time is that
what this is I mean so I become
conflicted so effective yeah so when I
heard other students were fighting third
wave members then that just meant they
didn't know what they were doing if they
knew what we were doing they would want
to join
and then there were also some students
who were so desperate to join that they
were excluded is this still Wednesday
God still wants that this is still
Wednesday this is it still I mean he's
got to be like I'm gonna run out of my
lesson plan by Friday yeah I mean Jones
knew everything was going on because
informers are literally telling him
everything that is going on like he's
getting information about everything at
this point and it's it's it's everybody
it's not just his main informers so yeah
well and he and he is taking he's taking
all this information in and this and he
is just going like I I think there's two
things happening I think that and I
can't say for sure but he was definitely
he definitely talked about how he was
slightly intoxicated by the power okay
that's kind of all I wanted to know but
at the same time I think he's fascinated
by how quickly this is happening sure
right but on both a teacher on both
accounts there's not any kind of
negative perception he's feeling
necessary no he also has yeah he also
understands this is weird so leaving
school so he's he's finding out what
someone was telling their best friend
like he's people are telling him [ __ ]
every right so because of this students
now don't know who to trust the three
official of formers were actually
interrogating other members on their own
to get as much information as they could
okay and they would give Jones detailed
reports even on conversations students
had with their parents okay with the
information Jones held mock trials
saying his secret police had given him
information and then he called a member
in class the member would stand up he
would tell them they had violated
like being seen fraternizing with known
revolutionaries and then the class would
start chanting in unison guilty guilty
guilty and the person be banished to the
library Sharia was like hello Cheri
walked by a friend in the hallway who
saluted her and Cheri did not return the
salute yeah she's been banished and her
friend was shocked and said what do you
you didn't return the salute and cherry
told her well she's not in the movement
and so I'm not gonna return the salute
and from that moment on her friend
acted like she didn't exist David
Miscavige went to high school a couple
of I don't know if it was more people
did this or if it was just these two
dudes but they used STD as a acronym for
strength through discipline and then
they were joking about it and then one
joked that STD meant stronger than dirt
because that was tide slogan at the time
okay and then they laughed and then he
went to class and was called out by
Jones for saying STD made stronger than
dirt and he looked at his friend his
friend just stared straight ahead and
then he was banished twice so no friends
good friends yes is her best friend
snitching on each other yes big brother
so hey more like strong under how stupid
is tied right now Jones insisted on
walking with two bodyguards that Dave
so the plots lost they would they would
walk the halls and as they walk they
would all salute in unison and students
would all salute back
and then one bodyguard fellows go it's
pretty good
we're basically taking it over and I'm
sorry mother what do you mean how was
school
interesting I'm just asking how school
yeah interesting and let me guess you
want to know how school was because I'm
my son your son interesting interesting
why you see you think because I'm your
son that you're allowed to have
knowledge of anything that goes on why
I'm just asking how school was I'm not I
don't there's the question again what
are you doing
mother do you like the library yeah I
yeah you do yeah I would like to go have
a good time and there was sherry won't
you oh sherry exactly you're part of the
breakers what I knew it from the day I
saw ya okay go to your room you're you
go to you go to my room I'm only your's
you don't say it what are you doing it's
a podcast people can't see I'm doing so
one bodyguard followed Jones into the
teachers lounge the bodyguards out there
just separate people did he hire two
legit bodyguards are these like seventh
graders well haven't gotten to yet but
he basically got guys from the car club
well they've I can't wait till you get
to it okay so they go to the teachers
lounge one of the bodyguards follows a
man and the English teacher looks at the
kid and says well you're not supposed to
be him in here cuz this you're a student
and the body card looks at the English
teacher and says quote I'm not a student
I'm a bodyguard by the way I ain't mrs.
Harris is pumpkin pie oh my god
so late in the day and if you're in the
teachers line at your teacher and you go
hey you can't be in here and so goes I'm
a bodyguard you're like well I don't
want to thank ya really how was your
little thing going that you're doing in
your class cuz there's students in here
who are like Nazis he's doing a signal
and as a slogan I like the library mrs.
Johnson no I don't look I'm not part of
the simulation or whatever it is I'm
just I'm an English teacher I'm just
here having a little bit spaghetti
before I go back to my class okay so
that's where I'm at
spaghetti huh don't talk to you this
it's a good meal to eat alone in the
living room do this you say yeah no I
know what you're saying this is
Wednesday I I'm aware of the day well I
we're teaching Dickens so I actually
have to get back to okay yeah your
student can stay I don't give a [ __ ]
okay
spaghetti up here yeah mine so I'm in
charge so sherry is getting curious
about what's happening in the class yes
sherry has a lot of time on her she's in
the library so she walked by the class
to see what was going on but she's so
fearful she doesn't look in the glass
she just walks behind it's like a side I
you know kind of deal yeah she's looking
for peripheral update yeah and the class
is standing room only so she's like and
people are waiting to get in oh my god
it's got a line this is there's a class
that's a club now there's it's a
sophomore class and our juniors and
seniors are going in and joining the
class I'm 31 I'd love to take a stab at
it too
so Jones begins to become concerned when
he realizes that the kids from the
higher up classes are joining
and especially when he learned that
students from two other nearby high
schools want to come named joy come on I
know there's no rules so far but you
can't leave your school I take one class
a week over there and that other one I
go to cover I do fascism at the other
one
and this one I do like science and stuff
so it's growing at an alarming rate
yes Jones is now concerned it could get
out of control but he keeps it going
fuelling it with fiery speeches about
the importance of discipline and
community so he's feeling it right
uh-huh
now by the end of Wednesday 3rd waves
membership had grown to 200 students but
how many how many students are there I
dunno I know that I don't know I didn't
I never that's the kind of there's a lot
a lot there's a lot of information
that's not so three classes what I mean
class size wise what are we talking 18
no it's a little yeah I'm gonna say
thirty thirty okay so we're talking
ninety so now we're up to like two
hundred so we were doubled in size yeah
as far as that bodyguard Jones would
later write that the bodyguard was one
of his Dumber students his name was
Robert Robert was a hard worker who
always sat in Jones classroom during
lunch alone because no one wanted to
even them and now this had given him a
purpose and meaning it's so weird
so the outcasts are being sucked in
they're part of something a kid a kid is
always how long kid is always a lotta
kid who's never had friend now this is a
thing that he can do ya know he has
power over people this is a nightmare
that night just a Bane started it is
that night Jones received a phone call
from a rabbi of a concerned parent okay
Jones quote I told them we were merely
studying the German personality he
seemed delighted and told me not to
worry he would talk to the parents and
calm their concern hey rabbi worried
yeah be bothered but like I said Jones
was liking it he liked the power and
control his wife told him to stop his
wife it was dangerous but still he knew
the experiment was you know getting out
of control
yeah okay this is out of control on
Thursday the third wavers I know it's
Thursday the third way was arrived at
school to find that the breakers which
was just Shelley had broken into Jones's
class and torn down all of their poster
and she taped her own posters up and
wrote on the board you know breakers
like it's basically like resist this
don't do this but it's just her yeah
okay the break-in to the third wave
headquarters was the talk of school the
entire day okay so now it's Watergate
now it's called the headquarters huh
yeah no it's definitely terms are
scarier that's us yeah that's all I was
doing so so she's putting up her own
posters in the first class in the
morning Jones counted 80 students he's
always supposed to have 30 Jones came in
with a bodyguard who's now his full-time
bodyguard okay members of the car club
appointed themselves his bodyguards
right yeah and one was now posted at the
door at all times because of the
break-in sure now even if there's no
class or whatever at lunch
there's someone posted at the door okay
watch the headquarters mm-hmm Jones
closed the curtains this first morning
close the curtains turn off the lights
shut the door unlocked it and made all
the members stand and stay still stay
standing okay and then started the day
by mock assassinating two of the
students he said you're assassinated in
you're assassinated go to the library go
to the library they were moved he then
told the students this is not a game
it's not just this class
he said the third wave was being used by
teachers all over the country 1025
schools and they're coordinating a
movement to create a third political
party that would take over the country
okay so he did have something for
Thursday what he didn't know he came in
and did it on the fly oh he didn't plan
any of this he would come in and just
something that hit him and he would
[ __ ] do it the students in the class
he said were essential to the revolution
and the ones who have been removed were
not up to it but you guys are quote
across the country teachers like myself
have been recruiting and training a
youth Brigade capable of showing the
nation a better society through
discipline community pride and action if
we can change the way this is girls run
this is really dangerous we can change
the way that factory stores universities
and all other institutions are run you
are selected you are a selected group of
young people chosen to help this cause
if you will stand up and display what
you have learned in the past four days
we can change the destiny of this nation
no one asked him for proof and there's
no way to get bright in some way before
the Internet is my way to look it up by
the way also you don't ask for proof in
this situation I mean you are in a call
then you get an F you go to the library
yeah so you just go to new nosing
questions no I'll give him the C John
said the third way it was being created
to address the many issues of the time
that began after the assassination of
President Kennedy
okay in 1967 there have been more
assassinations the civil rights battle
was raging and most importantly the
Vietnam War was on and all of these kids
were looking at the draft in a couple of
years and the third wave now seems like
an answer mm-hmm to possibly being
drafted that's why that's why this is
like it now that that's why it now I am
like this is dangerous
so the third wave can actually save
their lives right if a new party is
being created with you
don't sell me you take over then to them
yes that's but that's why this is that's
great this is veering into the state of
uncontrollable nature in a bad way
now there's also a lot of disenchantment
after the killing of Kennedy that he'd
been tapping into so this was a real
youth movement to change the world
tomorrow the students were told they
would meet the 3rd waves presidential
candidate and an assembly and the new
leader were giving an address on TV on
the fly yeah what's his plan yeah I
gotta go honey
Kate go out tonight I gotta find a
presidential candidate maybe this wasn't
on the fly maybe this party thought up
about the presidential candidate
beforehand so it seems believable
especially because a student in the back
of the room holds up a magazine he had
brought in and inside it was a two-page
ad and and no one can remember what it's
for but it's like Time magazine or
something and AD is a two-page as it
says the third wave is coming so there's
just this crazy for instance really on
this day and the kid shows us so then
Ron sees that and he's like he points to
his proof as there see right the third
wave right there in Scott is coming
Thank You Darren good stuff Darren and
then and then he abruptly walked out
okay so the the you know you're a kid in
the class and the teacher says this and
then a kid pulls out an ad you're oh
yeah you're famous you're in we're
awesome we're gonna change the world
history will take note of us so he
could've was you know he probably walked
out I might my thought when I heard that
he probably walked out was is that
that's sort of a peak like when the kid
pulls out the ad now you walk out
because if he stays there it could be
questioned or whatever so he shuts down
any sort of ability so because they
can't question it with each other so
he's put it out there he's got a backup
proof now he's out there now into the
bathroom to cry about how amazing this
was going he was like there are no
worlds left to conquer I'm the greatest
so he says the announcement for the big
reel the next the next day is completely
unexpected even for him he doesn't know
what he's doing the announcement of the
next day with the presidential yeah he
doesn't know he he knows he made that
announcement he doesn't know what he's
gonna do
so now every student is completely on
board some had just up to this point for
sherry she's in library like guys these
will he's weird
it says someone just been going along
for the grade but then others were like
into it but then this now has completely
flipped on its head like it's become
like a [ __ ] thing well now they think
they're gonna change the world so some
some apparently never believe it but you
know sounds like a lot a lot so one girl
after this happens up he leaves
tells them not good not to go to the
assembly tomorrow that this is
completely wrong the rest of the class
just stays silent by the way how about
this do us all a favor get a head start
to the library okay
get walking to the library so you know
and one of the reasons they're not doing
is because it's a there they're actually
thinking was a part of a country right
movement and if they blow it if their
school blows it they're under this like
idea that if they blow it the whole
thing falls apart so they're now like
well I'm I'm doing some that could say
the lives of a bunch other kids right
from the more diverse so they're
enormous empowerment so their minds are
blown they're sworn to secrecy one a
student however told her mom and her mom
called and told the school counselor and
then a school counselor went to talk to
Jones and Jones exiled the student to
the library oh she did that's
interesting well I will figure it out
when she comes into class today
Thank You Debbie oh hey Karen hey how
are you good
yeah now I want you to know that
I have heard some your concerns what no
no no concern can you have concerns
I don't Karen I don't right here--an hmm
you have concerns I do have concerns and
you raise them and I'm happy you did I
didn't I'm happy you did all right look
I talked to your mother
I talked Nona and don't get upset what
don't get upset
I talked to your mother well yes but but
but again because you know I think you
mentioned something does my mom an
informer no no no no no no why did you
do that you did with your eyes I'm your
mother's she doesn't have the tightest
of lips so she's saying some things that
maybe she shouldn't around here but but
Karen what I want you to know is that
the third wave respects what you do and
that's what makes it so grad assisting I
feel to tell you yeah - pack your book
bag doctor because you're going to the
library and get to the library
you go to the library hey tell sherry I
said what's up go to the library yeah
keep yapping keep yappin I'm Hitler now
but it's Thursday at 1:45 and I'm Adolf
Hitler coupler high school or whatever
it's called
so another student told his parents that
they shouldn't go to work tomorrow but
to be by TV at noon the next day because
something really big was gonna go down
hey guess what our kids gonna kill
someone
I'm like I know during the entire
experiment when parents would call to
complain the principal stood up for
Joan's methods and explained that he
what he was doing is it's a solitary I
don't understand that what he's trying
to do is create the Third Reich in the
school it's pretty out of the box
no one knew Jones was making it up as he
went along not even the principal okay
the next day on the way so
so - okay so the next day it's Friday
now right yes the students arrived and
John's not in the classroom two
bodyguards from the car club are there
and they said they're gonna escort the
students to the assembly in room H one
okay so it's a good almost theater II
type sure thing
a female student spoke up and told the
others not to go she was written up by
her classmates
one other female student stayed behind
as all the other students headed out so
just from just you know so the four
people that stand out as standing up to
whatever's going on are all women mm-hmm
which I find very interesting I mean
Dave that feels like it's a knock
against guys a little bit don't be raise
your hand just do it the guy says stupid
so the lecture hall each one fills up
with about 200 third wavers some who'd
come from other schools I'm weird again
body guards are standing at the doors
sure the news media had heard about
what's going on and have now arrived to
cover it there are television cameras
there are reporters photographers so in
a lot of ways the appearance of this is
now exactly what he's talking about
yeah okay the lights are off the halls
dark Jones is standing at a podium
everyone sitting in ease as they've been
taught and stiff put their hands on
their back and Jones that said quote let
us show everybody the extent of our
training and they sit up and belted out
their slogan strength through discipline
strike for your community strike through
action and while they did this they held
up their sea salutes is there it's just
Friday
is there is there any student who's like
he wasn't it weird that candy-ass last
week about how the Nazis came to be yeah
I think there are some students but
again he's crossed this line when he did
yeah well at this point you're like
yeah so I mean this is he has created
he's genuinely created a reality so they
start their chants quiet and then of
ratchet up to her just a [ __ ] yelling
raw sure John's then had them sit at
attention there was a television in
front of the class John said the party
leader would come on at any moment he
turned on the screen which just showed
snow right and then he left
and then the bodyguards left and nothing
happened and after a while the TV crews
and reporters left a few students but
almost all the students stayed in their
seats seated staring ahead that's no
that's no and this went on for a little
bit and then one student started looking
around and saw everyone was just staring
blankly and he said they looked dead to
him and with the doors closed Jones the
bodyguards and reporters gone his mind
went to a concentration camp because
that's what they did when they
exterminated Jesus they shut the doors
and dropped gas down and so he's
picturing gasping dropped from above and
he thinks oh my god they trapped us in
here and they're gonna kill us
and he panics and he stood up and he
yelled I'm getting the hell out of here
he was convinced the doors are locked
and they were trapped so he was the
first one to run other students jumped
up and started running to the doors in
panic as soon as they reached the doors
the lights came on and Jones was
standing in the back of the hall and he
started whispering the mattress strength
through discipline that stuff he's
trying to calm them down now and it
works the students joined him and sir
whispering until everything has calmed
down and then someone yells there is no
party leader is there and Jones turns on
a projector playing a documentary about
Nazi youth oh my god
I mean is he like give me eight mics to
drop hey me all the mics thank you
what and he said quote there is no
leader there's no such thing as a
national youth movement called the third
wave you have been used manipulated
shoved by your own desires into the
place you now find yourself you're no
better or worse than the German Nazis we
have been studying what these can be the
what they're like a lot of students
start to cry oh my god
quote shocked the look of shock was like
the earth was ending they didn't know
what to do they couldn't walk they were
sitting down some people wanted to leave
but didn't know whether to leave or not
I thought you guys know I think there's
no we're doing and their hug each other
they're weeping one student went to
Shelly and told her it was over Oh
Shelly I thought it was Shari what no I
might be wrong well whatever whatever
whatever so they go to go to her and
tell her it's over and she thought quote
oh my god they found me out so when they
come up when a student walked up to her
and said it's over her first thought was
they found it on the breakers like her
first one is like the man the absolute
edge yeah but then she was told no the
movements over and she was being called
back to the classroom okay so she goes
into the classroom and when she went in
she said the students seem like mirages
they were trembling and she felt like if
she just flicked at them they would fall
over she's like I read a really good
book on lizards so the year Jones did
this was the year he was up for tenure
oh man and he was already hated by the
conservative school board and other
teachers so he was [ __ ]
he lost his tenure and he was fired
there were protests like the students
came out and held a massive rally Pro
him Pro hit right because they still
love him even though I mean again well
you hit as much as as much as it was
horrible like now you literally
understand how fascism happens Dave I
mean that is as well
after a week of that that is as
well-equipped as one can be to fight and
and be aware of propaganda yep
so there's protests to keep him there
and a movement to try to keep him but
then mr. Jones announced he'd be leaving
anyway because Germany called they're
really they want me there for some
reason I don't know what's going on
because the school board was gonna
restrict his teaching method so he's
like I can't stay here because they're
not gonna let me do right they were like
cults and and authoritarian government
school we're not saying that you can't
teach what you want but there will be
yeah we also are hype Nazi tension yeah
we just don't want like a Nazi or like a
Mussolini situation happening with you
know a lot of what I was gonna do in
March yeah well like brown shirts or any
of that stuff like sports are cool you
know I mean like sports are fine like a
fascist movement with yeah not great oh
I think you're gonna leave me in the
other room now it's not good so he left
Coverley to teach in San Francisco the
students felt a tremendous loss this is
what the principle of the experiment
said quote I don't think it was out of
control as a methodology or as a unit of
learning I thought it got out of control
when he took that learning and tried to
apply it to his contemporary school he
was actually coaching the United student
movement which had nothing to do
directly with his class but that's what
I think is the immorality of what Rahm
Jones did he took his advantage as a
teacher with a guaranteed audience of
young people to try to indoctrinate them
he wasn't teaching them he was
indoctrinating them and that's what I
think his mistake was it's his purpose
his intent rather than his actual
teaching that was the problem okay
I mean to me I'm like I can't yeah I you
almost can't separate them what it's
it's all kind of one lumped in yeah
thing as far as like yeah I mean are you
in or are you out
I can't I don't think there's a way to
really split hairs over like I mean did
did what he did what he
did did it make the point very much made
the point very much made the point yeah
but Jonas is never able to teach again
the way he wanted he works with adults
now with special needs teaching them
poetry and things like that he's also a
noted author and playwright and today he
says there's no way he would do the
third wave he sees the experiment as a
quote a big error made by a young
teacher and he realizes now that what he
did was extremely dangerous
he wrote a short story about it ten
years later which was turned into a play
and then a TV special the wave is now
required reading in Germany Israel and
some places in the United States the
majority of students who participated
don't regret being involved one student
went as far as to create the third wave
Institute in order to continue the
discussion about how quickly fascism can
rise in society would be amazing if it
was like we're keeping it going your
vision is still true once we get the
right candidate we're ready yeah Wow
I I think what a crazy mean to me the
most startling thing is how and and this
is what and this is what I have read
about when you read about when
authoritarian state over or whatever
fascism that it does happen super
quickly day I mean I think you can even
I mean I think you can even see it you
see it now I mean yeah it's again it's
not within a week this guy well bus guy
delivers like GrubHub but when but when
like we're not there to the point where
you don't want to talk to your neighbors
or you can't trust anybody to say
anything but we're we're super close to
you know I mean there's there's a lot of
there's a lot of dudes in the army it's
a massive amount who are both keepers
and crazy crazy religious Handmaid's
Tale ish and religious type dudes and
they yearn for this so we have a large
and there's always been a large section
of American society and pretty much all
societies didn't want fascism mm-hmm bad
that's just the reality of the situation
there are fascist parties
running for office in every European
country that's just how it is some and
now America gets that yeah now we've now
they're out and about and they're public
and they're going to always be there
yeah they're not always gonna call
themselves fascists but they're gonna
have fascist ideals that is one of that
that's such a weird episode this I
should say is it a weird like that is it
is I mean it's just kind of [ __ ]
brilliant oh it's brilliant
what did well because because the first
of all you have to like his
psychological understanding of how
people work to be able to pull that off
but also like to be able to just take
those things and apply them and make
them work well to me it's a passion to
continue to do it and then you know
having first you go
okay here's our new carrot yeah like
repeatedly it I it is surprising how
quickly and effective it was part of it
is probably that you are dealing with
like you know I think maybe a school is
a place where it is a little more like
heightened as far as do you belong do
you not belong yeah there's a huge and
then the war is about that and then the
war and then the Kennedy stuff like
you're talking about all that but still
you would think that more connections in
the moment would be made and more people
would be vocal about but just the fact
that happened from Monday to Friday it's
yes there's the I mean I kept going back
and going this isn't right right this
doesn't but there's a so most of this
was taken from a documentary which is on
if you have Amazon it's on Amazon Prime
it's called the lesson plan and it it
literally does it it just goes Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and you're just like
what's happening how is it [ __ ]
Friday and this is all any other kid
ready to kill and you end there talking
to students who are now older and
talking about what they were thinking
and feeling and it's just you're just
like jesus [ __ ] christ it's literally
it's but the Big Brother thing you
brought up it's it's that thing where no
one wants to talk no one wants to speak
out like once you clamp down on that oh
and what's [ __ ] game well and once
once you start to show you know it's it
really is true and it's unfortunately
the world we are kind of pining for like
you're saying but it is like once you
start once you start to replace reward
with fear and then you show people many
ways to get rewards within that fear
based system they will do it yeah I mean
and that's what is very troubling about
today's little fragile world and yeah
and so they're the most interesting
thing and I think we can in our in our
society right now is you have people who
are like [ __ ] those fascism we have to
stopped it and then you have the
fascists and then you have this big
group in the middle who want to go like
can we just go back to the way it was
yes and you're this people who are
getting seized or going along like those
are the people old friends they're
they're not stepping up to fight they're
not stepping up to do anything they're
just like so I just want to keep my
house in my car and just hang out and
not do anything like well eventually
well you're like your party you're like
this bubble is either gonna get bled out
or popped oh yeah so you pick because
but they they cannot see it now I know
but it is I mean that's that's what gets
you dystopia yeah is by saying you know
a little things like well no now is the
time to sort of say I'm willing to
sacrifice my car my home to like fall on
the sword for the greater good
we have a lot of politicians in this
country who want to keep their jobs and
want to keep taking money from Google
and and lyft and uber and don't want to
actually step up and kick this thing in
the nuts
yeah and those are the ones that are the
worst and well how about here mostly
they're mostly Democrats who are corrupt
that are doing there's a lot of
Democrats that are trying to fight it
but there's a lot I don't care what I
define as corrupt fascinating about the
Democrats
the ones in charge is the way that they
say let's do this let's investigate
let's not do the financial stuff sir
what are you saying say well no let's
let's get them I mean obviously Trump is
he's up
Oh God for Matt oh we can't take four
more years of this let's get him on the
let's not to get into his financial
stuff and then it's like that's that's
Curran weird caveat corruption is what
leads to fascism it's worth everything
when there's law and you see now look
they're all in one car the second we try
to take the keys away we see the
technologist yeah anything in that car
they just wanted to keep and like
everyone has to understand fascism now
because as climate change happens and
things start to break down you're
literally gonna have a battle between
eco fascism and eco socialism like the
the fascists are already using yeah
they're already using climate change oh
yeah to get done what they want done oh
yes no they're doing that they actually
I would say the more prepared side has
been the side that has said forever we
just need to keep saying it's futile it
either doesn't exist or it's futile yeah
and one of those will always work yeah
yeah good stuff good all right well
that's fun
gobble-gobble everybody hope everyone's
happy our minds are super simple we read
the other source Jones's own essay at
the Third Way of 1967 I count those are
the two sources all right your minds a
little your futures manipulated there's
no need to really bother for independent
thought because the people standing next
to you are not capable of it they'll be
taken advantage of and they'll stab you
for Corn Pops all right gang
stop pakka sticks see in the library